le jour se lève dans les sentiers de la
nature du zoo sauvage de saint-félicien
italien c'est une journée bien spéciale
pour le directeur des collections il a
découvert la plus grande tanière jamais
vu dans l'histoire du zoo elle abritait
il ya quelques mois une femelle et ses
deux oursons les résidents n'y sont plus
c'est l'occasion de la visiter gvt au
début pour vraiment se traîner sous le
vent d'un petit peu avec les sur les
cours après ça on va enlever dans une
chambre un petit peu plus grave à ce
moment alors si vous sentez pas bien
long pour virer c'est que c'est possible
de revivre et là mais si ça va bien on
sera un peu plus loin il ya une autre de
l'otan d'or par tonne ou a pas mal
les très grandes options plus qu'à
l'intérieur de ces charlots chaque stand
une demi heure et demie bon il va
l'entraîner pas de tout repos
le tunnel s'étend sur plus de 6 m à
l'extrémité la dernière des deux
chambres où trois hommes peuvent
s'entasser pour un pot pot pour une
tanière d'or ça c'est vraiment agréable
on oppose souvent des grands tania com
com comme cela c'est vraiment agnac
équipe qu'ils étaient construits en
bolivie les griffe d'ours l'api progrès
qu'a tout les uns ya écrit encore un
petit peu j'imagine que dans quelques
années votre concurrent utiliser de
novembre à avril pour l'hibernation les
tanières comme celle ci peuvent parfois
être fréquentée l'été elles vont revenir
à l'occasion pour avoir refusé à
l'occasion par des mâles pour dans des
des journées qui sont très chaudes venir
dormir dans un prêche dans dans des
paniers
bref une bonne raison de ne pas
s'éterniser et si l'entrée était un défi
sortir l'est tout autant
je peux vous dire que même si c'est une
et ma tanière
on sent extrêmement les trois là dedans
une espèce de phénomènes ce qui se passe
je sais pas trop avec la pression mais
on sent un peu un certain manque d'air à
l'intérieur et ça fait du bien de voir
la lumière du soleil
preuve que c'était le bon temps pour
quitter dès notre départ ce gros ours
est venu inspecter la tanière question
de savoir qui était chez lui ici maxime
corneau radio canada saint félicien